A lot of the important work on neural
networks happened in the 80's and
in the 90's but back then computers
were slow and datasets very tiny.
The research didn't really find many
applications in the real world.
As a result, in the first decade of
the 21st century neural networks have
completely disappeared from
the world of machine learning.
Working on neural networks
was definitely fringe.
It's only in the last few years, first
seeing speech recognition around 2009,
and then in computer vision around 2012,
that neural networks
made a big comeback.
What changed?
Lots of data and cheap and fast DBU's.
Today, neural networks are everywhere.
So if you're doing anything with data,
analytics or
prediction, they're definitely something
that you want to get familiar with.
So let's get started.